again we're getting it back
exactly when did president trump learn
of the breach of the capital
and what specific actions did he take to
bring the rioting to an
end and when did he take them please be
as detailed
as possible the house managers have
given us
absolutely the other on to that question
uh we're able to piece together a
timeline
uh and um it goes all the way back to
the
december 31st january 2nd there is a lot
of
interaction between the authorities
and getting folks to
have security beforehand on the day
we have a tweet uh at 2 38 so it was
certainly
some time before then with the
rush to bring this impeachment there's
been absolutely no investigation into
that
and that's the problem uh with this
uh entire proceeding the house managers
did zero investigation and the american
people
deserve a lot better than coming in here
with no evidence hearsay
on top of hearsay on top of reports that
are of hearsay
due process is required
here and that was denied
mr president
of nevada mr president i send a question
to the desk
the senator from nevada senator rosen
submits a question for the
house managers
and the clerk will read it
on january 6 the anti-semitic proud boys
group
that president trump had told to stand
by
laid siege to the capitol alongside
other rioters
including one wearing a camp auschwitz
shirt is there evidence that president
trump knew or should have known
that his tolerance of anti-semitic
speech
hate speech combined with his own
rhetoric could incite the kind of
violence
we saw on january 6th
mr president senators donald trump has a
long history
of praising and encouraging violence as
you saw he has espoused hateful rhetoric
himself he has not just tolerated it
but he's encouraged hateful speech by
others he has refused
as you saw in the september debate that
interview to condemn
extremists and white supremacist groups
like the proud boys
and he has at every opportunity
encouraged and cultivated
actual violence by these groups
yes he has encouraged actual
violence not just the word fight
he told groups like the proud boys who
had beaten people with baseball bats
to stand by when his supporters in the
50-car caravan
tried to drive a bus of biden campaign
workers off the road
he tweeted a video of that incident with
fight music attached to it and wrote
i love texas when his supporters sent
death threats
to the republican secretary of state
raffensberger
in georgia he responded by calling mr
rathensberger
an enemy of the state after he knew
of those death threats and in the
morning of the second million mega march
when it erupted in violence and burned
churches he began that day with the
tweet
we have just begun to fight i want to be
clear that donald trump is not on trial
for those prior statements however that
hateful
and violent and inappropriate they may
be
but his statements the president's
statements
make absolutely clear three important
points for our case
first president trump had a pattern and
practice of praising and encouraging
violence
never condemning it it is not a
coincidence that those very same people
proud boys organizers of the trump
caravan
supporters and speakers of the second
million mega march
all showed up on january 6 to an
event that he had organized with
those same individuals who had organized
that violent attack
second his behavior is different
it's not just that it was a comment by
an official
to fight for a cause this is months of
cultivating a base of people who were
violent not potentially violent
but were violent and that that prior
conduct
both helped him cultivate the very group
of people that attacked us
it also shows clearly that he had with
that he had that group assembled
inflamed
and all the public reports ready to
attack he deliberately encouraged them
to engage in violence on january 6.
president trump had spent months calling
his supporters
to a march on a specific day
at a specific time for a specific
purpose what else were they going to do
to stop the certification of the
election
on that day but to stop you
but to stop you physically there was no
other way particularly
after his vice president said that he
would refuse
to do what the president asked the point
is this
that by the time you call the calvary
cavalry
not calvary but cavalry
of his thousands of supporters on
january 6
an event he had invited them to he had
every reason to know that they were
armed violent and ready
to actually fight he knew who he was
calling
and the violence they were capable of
and he still gave his marching orders
to go to the capitol and quote
fight like hell to stop the steel
how else was that going to happen
if they had stayed at the ellipse maybe
it would have just been too
violently in in fight in protest with
their words
but to come to the capitol that is why
this is different
and that is why he must be convicted and
acquitted
and disqualified
mr president on behalf of senator scott
of south carolina and myself
i'd like to submit a question to the
desk
senator tennessee shall submit
thank you
the question is for um counsel for the
former president from senators hagerty
and
scott of south carolina clerk will
read the question
given that more than 200 people have
been charged for their conduct at the
capitol on january 6
that our justice system is working to
hold the
appropriate persons accountable and that
president trump is no longer
in office isn't this simply a political
show trial that is designed designed to
discredit
president trump and his policies and
shame the 74 million americans
who voted for him
thank you senators for those that
question uh that's precisely
what the 45th president believes this
gathering is about
we believe in law and order and trust
that the
federal authorities that are conducting
investigations and
prosecutions in against the criminals
that invaded this building
will continue their work and be as
aggressive and thorough
as we know them to always be and that
they will continue to identify those
that entered the inner sanctum of our
government
and uh desecrated it the
45th president no longer holds office
there is no sanction available under the
constitution in our view
for him to be removed from office that
he
no longer holds the only logical
conclusion is that the purpose of this
gathering
is to embarrass the 45th president of
the united states
and in some way try to create
an opportunity for senators to suggest
that he should not be permitted to hold
office in the future
or at the very least publicize this
throughout the land
to try to damage his ability to run for
office
when and if he is acquitted and
at the same time tell the 40
74 million people who voted for them
that their choice was
the wrong choice i believe that that
this is a divisive way of going about
handling impeachment and it denigrates
the
the great solemnity that should attach
to such proceedings
i yield the remainder of my time mr
president
mr president senator from massachusetts
president i send a question to the house
manager for the house managers to the
desk because the
president's
the senator will send the question
the debate's not allowed
the question is from senator markey
with senator duckworth to the manager of
the part of the house representatives
the clerk will
read the question
exactly when did the president learn of
the breach at the capitol
and what steps did he take to address
the violence
please be as detailed as possible
just wish to respond
mr president senators
this attack was on live tv on all major
networks
in real time the president as president
has access to intelligence information
including reports from inside the
capitol
he knew the violence that was underway
he knew the severity of the threats
and most importantly he knew the capitol
police were overwhelmingly outnumbered
in a fight for their lives against
thousands
of insurgents with weapons we know he
knew that
we know that he did not send
any individuals we did not hear any
tweets
we did not hear him tell those
individuals
stop this is wrong
you must go back we did not hear that
so what else do the president do we are
unclear
but we believe it was a dereliction of
his duty
and that was because he was the one
who had caused them to come to the
capitol and they were doing what he
asked them to do so there was no need
for him
to stop them from what they were engaged
in
but one of the things i would like to
ask is we still have
not heard and posed to you all the
questions that were raised by mr raskin
manager raskin
in his closing argument why did the
president trump
not tell the protesters to stop as soon
as he learned about it
why did president trump do nothing to
stop the attack
for two hours after the attack began
why did president trump do nothing to
help protect the capital
and law enforcement battling the
insurgents
you saw the body cam of a capital police
officer
at 4 29
still fighting 4
29 after since
what time one two o'clock in the
afternoon
why did he not condemn the violent
insurrection on january 6.
those are the questions that we have as
well
and the reason this question keeps
coming up is because the answer
is nothing
mr president the senator muta i send a
question to the desk
the senator from utah mr romney on
bf himself and senator collins
it's a question and
clerk will read it
um
oh and i apologize the question is for
both sides so the time will be
evenly divided when president trump sent
the disparaging tweet
at 2 24 p.m regarding vice president
pence was he aware that vice president
had been removed from the senate by the
secret service
for his safety
the house manager
and time will be evenly divided between
of course would the clerk read the
question again
when president trump sent the
disparaging tweet at 2
24 pm regarding vice president
pence was he aware that the vice
president had been removed
from the senate by the secret service
for his safety
the house of representatives managers
are recognized two and a half minutes
thank you well let me tell you what he
said at 2
24 p.m he said mike pence
didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done to protect our
country
and our constitution the usa demands the
truth
and you know by now what was all over
the media you couldn't turn on the
television couldn't turn on the radio
couldn't consume any media or probably
take any phone calls or anything else
without hearing about this and also
hearing about the vice president
and here's what donald trump had to know
at that time
because the whole world knew it all of
us knew it
live television had by this point shown
that the insurgents were already inside
the building
and that they had weapons and that the
police were outnumbered
and here are the facts they're not in
dispute
donald trump had not taken any measures
to send help
to the overwhelmed capitol police as
president at that point when you see all
this going on and the people around you
are imploring you
to do something and your vice president
is there
why wouldn't you do it
donald trump had not publicly condemned
the attack the attackers or told them to
stand down
despite multiple pleas to do so and
donald trump
hadn't even acknowledged the attack
and after wednesday's trial portion
concluded senator tuberville
spoke to reporters and confirmed the
call that he had with the president
and did not dispute manager sicilini's
description
in any way that there was a call between
he and the president
around the time that mike pence was
being ushered out of the chamber
and that was shortly after 2 pm
and senator tuberbill specifically said
that he told the president
mr president they just took the vice
president out
i've got to go that was shortly after
2pm
there were still hours of chaos and
carnage and mayhem the vice president
and his family
were still in danger at that point
our commander in chief did nothing
counsel for the former president
the answer is no at no
point was the president informed the
vice president was in any danger
because the house rushed through this
impeachment in seven days
with no evidence there is nothing at all
in the record on this point
because the house failed to do even a
minimum amount of due diligence
what the president did know is that
there was a violent
there was a violent riot happening at
the capitol
that's why he repeatedly called via
tweet and via video for the rides to
stop to be peaceful
to respect capital police and law
enforcement and to commit
no violence and to go home
but to be clear this
is an article of impeachment for
incitement
this is not an article of impeachment
for anything else
it's a one count they could have charged
anything they wanted they chose
to to to charge incitement
so that the question although answered
directly no
it's not really relevant to the charges
for the impeachment in this case and i
just wanted to
clear up one more thing mr castro
in his first answer may have spoke but
what he said was mr trump had said
fight to the death that's false i'm
hoping he misspoke
thank you
mr president
the the senator from minnesota mr
president
on behalf of myself and senators casey
and brown i send a question to the desk
this is a question from senator colbert
senator casey senator
brown to the house managers the clerk
will report
in presenting your case you relied on
past precedents
from impeachment trials such as william
belknap's impeachment after what you
have presented in the course of this
trial
if we do not convict former president
trump
what message will we be sending to
future presidents
and congresses
president trump engaged in a course of
conduct
that inciting an armed attack on the
capitol
he did so while seeking to overturn the
results of the election
and thwart the transfer of power
and when the attack began he further
incited violence
aimed to his own vice president even has
demonstrated
his state of mind by failing to defend
us
and the law enforcement officials who
protect us
the consequences of his conduct were
devastating
on every level police officers were left
overwhelmed unprotected
congress had to be evacuated our staff
barricaded in this building calling
their families to say goodbye
some of us like mr raskin had children
here
and these people in this building some
of whom were on the fbi's watch list
took photos stole laptops destroyed
precious statues
including one of john lewis
desecrated the statue of a recently
deceased
member of congress who stood
for non-violence this was devastating
and the world watched us
and the world is still watching
us to see what we will do
this day and we'll know what we did
this day one hundred years from now
those are the immediate consequences and
our actions will reverberate
as to what are the future consequences
the extremists who attack the capital at
the president's provocation
will be emboldened all our intelligence
agencies
have confirmed this it is not
house manager saying that there are
quite literally
standing by and standing ready
donald trump told them this is only
the beginning they are waiting and
watching
see if donald trump is right that
everyone said
this was totally appropriate
let me also bring something else up i'll
briefly say
that defense counsels put a lot of
videos out
in their um in their defense
playing clip after clip of black women
talking about fighting for a cause or an
issue or a policy
it was not lost on me is so many of them
were people of color
and women black women black women like
myself
who are sick and tired of being sick and
tired for our children
your children our children
this summer things happened that were
violent
but there were also things that gave
some of us black women
great comfort seeing amish people from
pennsylvania
standing up with us members of congress
fighting up with us and so i thought we
were past that
i think maybe we're not there are
long-standing consequences
decisions like this that will define
who we are as a people who america
is we have in this room
made monumental decisions you all
have made monumental decisions we've
declared wars
passed civil rights acts ensured that no
one in this country
is a slave every american
has the right to vote unless you live in
a territory
at this time some of these decisions
are even controversial but history has
shown
that they define us as a country and as
a people
today is one of those moments
in history will wait for our decision
mr president senator from your job i
send a question to the desk
hey senator from utah mr lee sends a
question on behalf of himself senator
hawley senator crapple senator blackburn
senator portman
and the question is
for the council for the former president
clerkle reed
multiple state constitutions enacted
prior to 1787
namely the constitutions of delaware
virginia pennsylvania and vermont
specifically provided for the
impeachment
of a former officer given that the
framers of the u.s
constitution would have been aware of
these provisions does their decision
to emit language specifically
authorizing the impeachment of former
officials indicate that they did not
intend
for our constitution to allow for the
impeachment of
former officials
good question
and the answer is yes of course they
left it out
the framers were very smart men and they
went over
draft after draft after draft on that
document
and they reviewed all the other drafts
of all of the state constitutions
all of them and they picked and
choosed what they wanted and they
discarded
what they did not
and what they discarded was the option
for all of you to impeach
a former elected official i hope that's
answering your question thank you
mr president
senator from california mr president i
sent a question to the desk
senator from california submits a
question
for the house managers the clerk report
having been on the front lines of
combating the
big lie over the past four years as
california's
chief elections officer it is clear that
president trump's plot to undermine
the 2020 election was built on lies
and conspiracy theories how did this
plot to unconstitutionally
keep president trump in power lead to
the radicalization
of so many of president trump's
followers
and the resulting attack on the capital
senators donald trump spent months
inciting his base to believe that their
election was stolen
and that was the point that was the
thing
that would get people so angry think
about that
what it would take to get a large group
of thousands of americans
so angry to storm the capital
that was the purpose behind donald trump
saying that the election had been rigged
and that the election had been stolen
and to be clear when he says the
election is stolen
what he's saying is that the victory and
he even says one time
the election victory is being stolen
from them
think about how significant that is to
americans
again you're right over 70 million i
think 74 million people voted
for donald trump and this wasn't a
one-off comment
it wasn't one time it was over and over
and over and over and over again
with a purpose
and we're not having this impeachment
trial here because donald trump
contested the election
as i said during the presentation and
nobody here wants to lose an election
we all run our races to win our
elections
but what president trump did was
different
would our that mob amped them up enough
to get out there and try to stop the
election results the certification of
the election
and y'all
they took over the senate chamber to do
that
they almost took over the house chamber
there were 50 or so or more house
members who were literally
scared for their lives up in the gallery
a woman who bought into that big lie
died because she believed the
president's big lie
this resulted in a loss of one of his
supporters lives
a capital police officer died that day
other of president trump's supporters
two capitol police officers ended up
taking their own lives
defense counsel their defense is
basically everything president trump
trump did is okay and he could do it
again
is that what we believe that there is no
problem with that
that it's perfectly fine if he does the
same thing all over again
this is dangerous he's inciting his base
he was using the claim of a rigged
election we have never
seen somebody do that over and over and
over again
tell a lie say six months ahead of time
that it's a rigged election
there is a dangerous consequence to that
when you've got millions of followers on
twitter and millions of followers on
facebook and you've got that huge bully
pulpit from the white house
and you're the president of the united
states
there is a cost to doing that
people are listening to you in a way
that quite honestly they're not
listening to me
and they're not listening to all of us
in this room
and i just want to clear up the defense
counsel made a point about
something that i read earlier defense
counsel suggested i misspoke
and i just want to clarify for the
record that the tweet i referenced
let me read you the tweet directly if a
democrat
presidential candidate had an election
rigged and stolen
with proof of such acts at a level never
seen before
the democrat senators would consider it
an act of war
and fight to the death mitch and the
republicans do nothing
just want to let it pass no fight
so donald trump was equating what
democrats would do
if their election was stolen he said
they'd fight to the death
why do you think he sends that tweet
because he's trying to say
hey the other side would fight to the
death so you should fight to the death
i mean do we read that any other way
mr president
the senator from missouri mr president
on my behalf and on behalf
of senator kramer i send a question to
the desk
senator hawley on behalf of himself and
senator kramer send a
question for the council
and house manager and following our
procedure the first one to respond after
the
it's read will be the counsel for the
former president
if the senate's power to disqualify is
not
derivative of the power to remove a
convicted president from
office could the senate disqualify
a sitting president but not remove him
or her
if the senate's power to disqualify is
not derivative
of the power to remove a convicted
president
from office could the senate disqualify
a sitting president but not remove
him or her
president as
two and a half minutes
now
but i can't let this rest
mr castro attributed a statement
the time before last that he was up here
that donald trump had told his people to
fight to the death
i'm not from here i'm not like you guys
i was being very polite and given
he got caught as they were caught
earlier
today with all of the evidence checking
tweets
switching dates everything they did and
bear in mind
i had two days
to look at their evidence and when i say
two days i mean they started putting in
their evidence so i started to be able
to get looking at it
that is not the way this should be done
but what we discovered was
he knew what he was doing he knew that
the president
didn't say that to his people what he
said was if it happened to the dems this
is what they would do
in his speech that day you know what he
said
he said if this happened to the
democrats if the election was stolen
from the democrats
all hell would break loose but he said
to his supporters
we are smarter we are stronger and we're
gonna
didn't do what they did all summer long
so what he did was he misrepresented
a tweet to you to put
forth the narrative that is wrong
it's wrong it's dishonest
and the american people don't deserve
this any longer
you must acquit
the managers on the part of the house
representatives have
two and a half minutes
and that was profoundly inaccurate and
irrelevant to what the question is so
i'm going to get back to the question
um so under article 2
section 4 a president who is in office
must be convicted before
removal um and and
um then must be removed before
disqualification okay but if the the
president is already
out of office then he can be separately
disqualified
as this president is but these powers
have always been treated
as separate which is why i think there
have been um
eight people who've been convicted and
removed and just three of them
disqualified
and as you know there's a totally
separate process within the senate for
doing this uh the constitution requires
two-thirds vote for conviction
but for disqualification it's a majority
vote
uh it's a separate thing so people could
vote to
[Music]
convict and then vote not to disqualify
if they felt that the evidence
demonstrated that the president was
guilty of incitement to insurrection
they could vote to convict but if they
felt that they didn't want to exercise
the further
power established by the constitution to
disqualify they wouldn't have to do
that and that could be something
that's taken up separately by the senate
by majority of it
mr president
the senator from massachusetts i send a
question to the desk
this
the senator from massachusetts has a
question for the
house managers the clerk will read the
question
the defense's presentation highlighted
the fact
that democratic members of congress
raised objections to counting of
electoral votes
in past joint sessions of congress
to your knowledge were any of those
democratic objections
raised after insurrectionists
stormed the capital in order to prevent
the counting of electoral votes
and after the president's personal
lawyer
asked senators to make these objections
specifically
to delay the certification
so um thank you very much mr president
for the opportunity to respond to that
um the answer is no we are not aware
that any other objections raised in
the counting of electoral college votes
either by democrats or republicans and
this has actually been
a kind of proud bipartisan tradition
under the electoral college just because
the electoral college is so arcane and
has so many rules to it
i think that my co-counsel on the other
side
had some fun because i was one of the
people who took i think about 30 seconds
in 2016 to point out that the electors
from florida
were not actually conforming to the
letter of the law because they have a
rule in florida that you can't be a dual
office holder in other words
you can't be like a state legislator and
also be an elector
and so that was in proper form but i
think the vice president
then vice president biden properly gave
me down and said look we're going to
try to make the electoral college work
and we're going to vindicate the will of
the people and that's pretty much what's
happened and
nobody has stormed the capitol before or
as
representative cheney the secretary of
the republican conference said
gone out and summoned a mob
assembled a mob incited a mob and lit
a match as representative cheney said
this would that all of this goes to
the doorstep of the president none of it
would have happened without him and
everything is due to his actions this
would not happen that is the
chair of the house republican conference
who was the the target of an effort to
remove her which was rejected
on a vote of by more than two to one in
the house republican conference
when there was an attempt to remove her
for voting for impeachment
and becoming a leader for vindicating
our constitutional values so please
don't
mix up what republicans and democrats
have done i think in
every election for a long time to say
there are improprieties going on in
terms of conforming with state
election laws with the idea of
mobilizing
a mob insurrection against the
government
that got five people killed 140 capital
officers
wounded and threatened the actual
peaceful succession of power and
transfer of power in america
if we want to talk about reforming the
electoral college
uh we can talk about reforming electoral
college you don't do it with violence
mr from north dakota thank you my
apologies to the senator for
massachusetts for butting in
i send a question to the desk for the
former president's attorneys
the question from senator kramer is for
the
council for the former president the
clerk will read the
question
given the allegations of the house
manager that president trump has
tolerated
anti-semitic rhetoric has there been a
more pro-israel
president than president trump
no but it's apparent that nobody
listened to what i said earlier today
because
the victoria speech needs to stop
you need to stop there was nothing fun
here mr raskin we aren't having fun here
this is about the most
miserable experience i've had down here
in washington dc
there's nothing fun about it and in
philadelphia
where i come from when you get caught
doctoring the evidence
your case is over
and that's what happened they got caught
doctoring the evidence and this case
should be over
the senator from vermont
the senator from vermont senator sanders
has a question for
both the uh council for the former
president
and house manager the clerk will read it
and following our procedure
the house managers will go first
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over
again that president trump was
perpetrating a big lie
when he repeatedly claimed that the
election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling a
big lie or in your judgment did trump
actually win
the election
the house managers have up to two and a
half minutes
things
as we all know president trump
did lose the election by 7 million votes
306 electoral votes
by the time of the january 6 attack the
courts
the justice department all 50 states
across the country had done
agreed that the votes were counted the
people had spoken
and it was time for the peaceful
transfer
of power as our constitution
and the rule of law demands
61 courts 61
courts the president went to that's fine
appropriate he lost
he lost he lost the election
he lost the court case as leader
mccollum
mcconnell recognized the day after the
electors certified the votes
on december 14th he said quote many
millions of us had hoped that the
presidential election
would yield a different result but our
system of government
has processes to determine who will be
sworn in on january 20th
the electoral college has spoken
patriotism sometimes there is a reason
to dispute an election
sometimes the count is close sometimes
we ask for a recount
go to courts all of that's appropriate
i lost my first election i stayed in bed
for three days
we do what we need to do and we move on
this
was not that because when all of these
people confirmed
that donald trump had lost when the
courts
his his department of justice
state officials congress his vice
president
were ready to commit to the peaceful
transfer of power
the peaceful transfer of power
donald trump was not ready and so we are
all here
because he was not ready day after day
he told his supporters false outlandish
claims
of why this election was rigged now
let's be clear
president trump had absolutely no
support of these claims
but that wasn't the point of what he was
doing he did it
to make his supporters frustrated
to make them angry
time is expired
and counsel for the former president
recognized for two and a half minutes
of course the clerk will read the
question again
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over
again that president trump was
perpetrating a big lie
when he repeatedly claimed that the
election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling a big lie
or in your judgment did trump actually
win the election
the uh council for the former president
have two and a half minutes
my judgment who asked that
my judgment's here relevant in this
proceeding absolutely is
what's supposed to happen here is the
article of impeachment
is the senate will
be in order um
under the rules cannot challenge the
content of the response the council will
continue
we have the question read again please
the house prosecutors have stated over
and over again
that president trump was perpetrating a
big lie when he repeatedly claimed
that the election was stolen from him
and that he actually won the election by
a landslide
are the prosecutors right when they
claim that trump was telling
a big lie or in your judgment did trump
actually win the election
in my judgment it's irrelevant to the
question before this body
what's relevant in this impeachment
article
is were mr trump's words
insightful to the point of violence and
riot
that's the charge that's the question
and the answer is no he did not have
speech that was insightful to violence
or riot now what's important to
understand here is
the house managers have completely
from the beginning of this case to right
now
done everything except answer that
question
the question they brought before you the
question they want my client
to be punished by
that's the questions that should be
getting asked
and the answer is he advocated
for peaceful patriotic
protests they're his words you've the
house managers
have showed zero zero
evidence that his words did anything
else
remember all of the evidence is this was
premeditated
the attack on the capitol was
pre-planned
it didn't have anything to do with mr
trump
in any way what he said on that day
on january 6 at that ellipse
and that's the issue before this senate
now on the issue of contesting
elections and the results the democrats
have a
long long history of just doing that i
hope everybody was able to see the video
earlier today
over and over again it's been contested
when mr trump was elected president
we were told that he was counsel was two
and a half minutes expired
oh okay the senator from wisconsin i'm
sorry i couldn't see who is uh
understand i send i sent a question to
the desk for both parties
so we'll go um
so
senator from wisconsin sends a question
um
for both council for the former
president and the
house managers uh clerk
will read it and the
council for the former president will
have the first two and a half minutes
the house managers assert that the
january 6th
attack was predictable and it was
foreseeable
if so why did it appear that law
enforcement at the capitol
were caught off guard and unable to
prevent the breach
why did the house sergeant-at-arms
reportedly
turn down a request to activate the
national guard
stating that he was not comfortable with
the optics
council former president is recognized
read the question again please
clerk will read the question again the
house managers
assert that the january 6th attack
was predictable and it was foreseeable
if so why did it appear that law
enforcement at the capitol
were caught off guard and unable to
prevent the breach
why did the house sergeant-at-arms
reportedly
turn down a request to activate the
national guard
stating that he was not comfortable with
the optics
holy cow that is a really good
question and had
the house managers done their
investigation maybe somebody would have
an answer to that
but they didn't they did zero
investigation they did nothing they
looked into nothing
they read newspaper articles they talk
to their friends who know a tv reporter
or something or something or another
but jiminy crickets there is no due
process
in this proceeding at all and that
question
highlights the problem when you have
no due process you have no
clear-cut answers but we do know
that there was i think a certain level
of foreseeability it looks like from the
information they were presenting
some law enforcement knew that something
could be happened i i was
in in my presentation we knew that the
mayor two days before
before had been offered
to have federal troops or
or national guard deployed beef up
security here in capitol
police it was offered so somebody had to
have an
inkling into something and my question
is
who ignored it and why
if an investigation were done
we would know the answer to that too
thank you
the house managers have two and a half
minutes
first if defense counsel has exculpatory
evidence
you're welcome to give it to us we would
love to see it
you've had an opportunity to give us
evidence that would esculpate the
president
haven't seen it yet everyone
the defense counsel wants to blame
everyone else
except the person who is most
responsible for what happened on january
6
and that's president trump donald trump
and he is the person who foresee this
the most
because he had the reports he had access
to the information
he as well had we all know how he is a
avid cable news watcher
he knew what was going to happen he
cultivated these individuals
these are the undisputed facts the
national guard was not deployed
until over two hours after the attack i
heard reference to mayor bowser
in defense's presentation mayor bowser
does not have authority
over the capitol or federal buildings
she could not deploy national guards
to the capitol that is outside of the
jurisdiction
of the mayor of the district of columbia
at no point in that entire day
did the president of the united states
our commander-in-chief
tell anyone law enforcement struggling
for their lives
insurgents who felt empowered by the
sheer quantity of them
any of us in this building or the
american people
that he was sending help he did not
defend
the capital the president of the united
states
did not defend the capital of this
country
it's unindefensible
mr president sergeant morgan
mr president i send a question to the
desk
foreign
senator merkley submits a question for
the house managers the clerk will
read the question
if a president spins a big lie to anger
americans
and stokes the fury by repeating the lie
at
event after event and invites
violent groups to dc on the day and hour
necessary to interrupt the electoral
college count
and does nothing to stop those groups
from advancing on the capitol
and fails to summon the national guard
to protect the capital
and then express his pleasure and
delight that the capital was under
attack
is the president innocent of inciting an
insurrection
because in a speech he says be peaceful
the house managers have five minutes
you all ask a very important question
which is given everything
that the president did leading up to the
election after the election
and leading up to january 6 all of the
incitement
of his supporters whom he convinced
with a big lie over and over that the
election had been stolen
from them and from him
and then once the mob had stormed the
capitol
the vice president was in danger the
speaker was in danger
the members of the house and the senate
and all the staff here the janitorial
staff the cafeteria workers
everybody
and all of the hot rhetoric that he
spoke with
and then simply a few times
said stay peaceful remember
he said stay peaceful when they had
already gotten violent
when they'd already brought weapons when
they'd already hurt people
what he never said was stop the attack
leave the capital leave immediately
and let me be clear the president's
message in that january six speech
was incendiary
so in the entire speech which was
roughly eleven hundred words
he used the word peaceful once
and using the word peaceful was the only
suggestion
of non-violence
president trump used the word fight or
fighting 20 times
now again consider the context he had
been telling him a big lie
over and over getting them amped up
getting angry because an election had
been stolen from them
there's thousands of people in front of
him some of them are carrying weapons
and arms
they're angry he's telling him to fight
and president trump's words in that
speech just like the mob's actions
were carefully chosen his words incited
their actions and how do we know this
for months the president had told his
supporters his big lie
that the election was rigged and he used
the lie to urge his supporters
not to concede and to stop the steel
if you rob the bank and on the way out
the door you yell
respect private property that's not a
defense to robbing the bank
mr president the senator from texas
mr president i send a question to the
desk directed at both sides
the senator from texas has a question
for
both sides the clerk will read it
and the house managers will go first for
two and a half minutes
out of their 16 hours the house managers
devoted
all of 15 minutes to articulating
a newly created legal standard for
incitement
one was violence foreseeable
two did he encourage violence
three did he do so willfully
is this new standard derived from the
criminal code
or any supreme court case
while violent riots were raging kamala
harris
said on national tv they're not going to
let up
and they should not and she also raised
money to bail out
violent rioters using the manager's
proposed standard
is there any coherent way for donald
trump's words
to be incitement and kamala harris's
words
not to be incitement
thank you mr president senators um
i'm not familiar with the statement that
is being referred to
with respect to the vice president but i
find it absolutely unimaginable
that vice president harris would ever
incite
violence or encourage or promote
violence
um obviously it's completely irrelevant
to the proceeding at hand and i will
allow her to defend herself um
the uh the the president's lawyers are
pointing out that we've never had any
situation like this before in the
history of the united states and it's
true there's never been a president
who has encouraged a violent
insurrection
against our own government so we really
have nothing to compare it to
so what we do in this trial
will establish a standard going forward
for all time
now there are two theories that have
been put before you and i think we've
got to
get past all of the the picayune little
critiques that have been offered today
about
this or that let's focus on what's
really at stake here
the president's lawyers say echoing the
president
his conduct was totally appropriate in
other words he would do it again
exactly what he did is the new standard
for what's allowable for him
or any other president who gets into
office our point is that
his incitement so overwhelms any
possible legal standard we have
that we've got the opportunity now to
declare that presidential
incitement to violent insurrection
against the capital in the congress
is completely forbidden to the president
of the united states
under the impeachment clauses so we set
forth for you the elements
of encouragement of violence and we saw
it overwhelmingly
we know that he picked the date of that
rally in fact there was a another group
that was going to rally another date and
he got it moved to january 1st
he synchronized it exactly with the time
that we would be enjoying
session and as representative cheney
said
he summoned that mob he assembled that
mob
he incited that mob he lit the match
come on get real
we know that this is what happened
and the second thing is the
foreseeability of it was it foreseeable
remember lansing michigan and everything
we showed you they didn't mention that
of course
remember the mega two march the mega two
rally they didn't mention that
violence all over the rallies the
president cheering it on
delighting in it reveling in it exalting
in it
come on how gullible do you think we are
we saw this happen
we just spent 11 or 12 hours looking at
all that
council for the former president has two
and a half minutes
senator cruz i believe the first part of
your question
refers to the newly created raskin
doctrine
on first amendment uh and
um he just in his answer actually he
gave you a new one
appropriateness the standard
that this body needs to follow
for law is brandenburg
v ohio and the test really the three
part test really comes out of bible
believers
versus wayne county to be specific
the speech has to be explicitly or
implicitly encouraged
the use of violence in other words it
has to be in the words itself
which is clearly it's not in the words
itself that's step one
they don't get past it two the speaker
intends that his speech will result
in use of violence or lawless action
there's no evidence of that
and it's ludicrous to believe that that
would be true
third the imminent use of violence or
lawless action is
likely to result in speech um
also they fail on all three points of
the law
as we know it and needs to be applied
here
i don't know why he said he never heard
kamala harris
say about the riots and the people
rioting
and ruining our businesses and our
streets that they're not going to let up
and they should not because we played it
three times today
we gave it to you in audio i read it to
you and you got it in video
that's what she said but it's protected
speech
her speech is protected also senator
that's the point
you all have protections as elected
officials
the highest protections under the first
amendment
and that first amendment applies here
in this chamber to this proceeding and
that's what you need to keep
focused on you need to keep focused on
what is the law
and how do we apply it to this set of
facts
it's your duty you get you can't get
caught up in all of the rhetoric and the
facts that are
irrelevant you need to keep focused
on what is the issue before you
decide it based on the law brandenburg
and bible believers
and apply it to the facts and that
requires you to look at the words
and there were no words of incitement
of anything
thank you mr president
the senator from washington president i
send a question to the desk
the senator from washington senator
murray has a question for the house
managers the
clerk will read the question
at 601 pm eastern time on january 6th
president trump tweeted these are the
things that happen
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away from great patriots who
have been
badly and unfairly treated for so long
adding for rioters to go home
[Music]
with love and in peace what is the
relevance of this tweet
to president trump's guilt
the house managers are
recognized for up to five minutes
senators this was a key quote and a key
statement by the president
that day that horrific day
remember the capital had been stormed
he'd been attacked people had yelled
hang mike pence
people had gone after speaker pelosi
people brought baseball bats and other
weapons
many members of congress and the senate
in the house were fearful for their own
lives
the president didn't call the national
guard
his own administration didn't list him
as somebody that they had spoken with
to activate the guard
and he said remember this day forever
so if he was not guilty of inciting this
insurrection
if this is not what he wanted if it
wasn't what he desired
by that time the carnage had been on
television for hours
he saw what was going on everybody saw
what was going on
if it wasn't what he wanted why would he
have said
remember this day forever why
commemorate
a day like that an attack on the u.s
capitol for god's sake
why would you do that unless you agreed
that it was something to praise
not condemn something to hold up and
commemorate
no no consoling the nation no reassuring
that the government was secure
not a single word that entire day
condemning the attack
or the attackers or the violent
insurrection
against congress
this tweet is important because it shows
two key points
about donald trump's state of mind first
this was entirely and completely
foreseeable
and he foresaw it
and he helped incite it over many months
he's saying i told you this was going to
happen if you certified the election for
anyone else besides me
and you got what you deserved for trying
to take it away from me
and we know this because that statement
was entirely consistent with everything
he said
leading up to the attack second
this shows that donald trump intended
and reveled in this
senators he reveled in this this is he
delighted in it this is what he wanted
remember this day forever he said not as
a day of disgrace as it is to all of us
but as a day of celebration and
commemoration
and if and if we let it if we don't hold
him accountable and set a strong
precedent
possibly a continuation later on
we will of course all of us remember
this day but not in the same way that
donald trump suggested
we'll remember the bravery of our
capital and metro police forces will
remember the officer who lost his lines
and sadly the others who did as well and
the devastation
that was done to this country because of
donald trump
the senator from louisiana mr president
i send a question to the desk
the senator from louisiana mr cassidy
has a question for both
council for the former president and um
uh counsel for the house the
clerk will read it and counsel for the
former president will go
first for two and a half minutes and
then the house representatives will have
two and a half minutes
senator tuberville reports that he spoke
to president trump
at 2 15 p.m he told the president that
the vice president had just evacuated
i presume it was understood at this time
that rioters had entered the capital
and threatened the safety of senators
and the vice president
even after hearing even after hearing of
this
at 2 24 pm president trump
tweeted that mike pence lacked courage
he did not call for law enforcement back
up until then
the tweet and lack of response suggests
president trump
did not care that vice president pence
was endangered
or that law enforcement was overwhelmed
does this show that president trump was
tolerant
of the intimidation of vice president
pence
down so it's two and a half minutes
directly now uh but
i dispute the premise of
your facts i dispute the facts that are
laid out
in that question and unfortunately
we're not going to know the answer to
the facts in this proceeding
because the house did nothing to
investigate what went on
we're trying to get here safe from mr
tuberville
there was hearsay from mr lee i think it
was two nights ago when we ended where
mr lee was accused of making a statement
that he never made but it was a report
from a reporter from a friend of
somebody who had some hearsay that they
heard
the night before at a bar somewhere i
mean that's
really the kind of evidence that the
house has brought before us
and so i have a problem with the facts
in the question because i have no idea
and nobody from the house has given us
any opportunity
to have any idea but mr trump and mr
pence have had a very good relationship
for a long time and i'm
sure mr trump very much is concerned and
was concerned
for the safety and well-being of mr
pence and everybody else that was
over here thank you
manager and part of the house
representatives had two and a half
minutes
thank you mr president um you know my
counsel said before
this has been my worst experience in
washington and for that i guess we're
sorry but man you should have been here
on january 6th
so the the council for the president
keep
blaming the house for not having the
evidence that's within
the sole possession of their client
who we invited to come and testify last
week
we sent a letter on february 4th i sent
it directly to president trump
inviting him to come and to explain
and fill in the gaps of what we know
about what happened there and they sent
back a contemptuous response
just a few hours later i think they
maybe even responded more quickly to my
letter than president trump did
in a as a commander-in-chief to the
invasion
and the storming of the capital of the
united states but in that letter i said
you know
if you decline this invitation we
reserve all rights including the right
to establish a trial that your refusal
to testify supports a strong adverse
inference what's that
well justice scalia was the great
champion of it if you don't testify in a
criminal case it can't be used against
you everybody knows that that's the
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination
but if it's a civil case and you plead
the fifth or you don't show up
then according to justice scalia and the
rest of the supreme court
you can interpret every disputed fact
against the defendant that is totally
available to us so for example
um if we say the president was missing
in action for several hours and he was
derelict in his duty and he
deserved his duty as commander-in-chief
and we say
that as inciter in chief he didn't call
off dogs and they say oh no he was
really doing whatever he can
if you're puzzled about that you can re
resolve that
dispute factual dispute against the
defendant who refuses to come to a civil
proceeding
he will not spend one day in jail if you
convict him this is not a criminal
proceeding
this is about preserving the republic
dear senate
that's what this is about setting
standards of conduct
for the president of the united states
so this never happens to us again
so rather than yelling at us and
screaming about how
we didn't have time to get all of the
facts about what your client did
bring your client up here and have him
testify under oath
about why he was sending out tweets
denouncing the vice president
of the united states while the vice
president was being hunted down by a mob
that wanted to hang him
and was chanting in this building hang
mike pence
hang mike pence traitor traitor traitor
time of the managers are up next
question
the senator from west virginia mr
president i send the question to the
desk
directed to the house managers
the senator from west virginia has a
question for the
house managers the clerk or report
would the president be made aware of the
fbi
and intelligence information of a
possible attack
and would the president be responsible
for not preparing to protect
the capital and all elected officials of
government
with national guard and law enforcement
as he did when he appeared when he
appeared
in front of the saint john's episcopal
church
it's the resp responsibility of the
president to know
president of the united states our
commander-in-chief
it's daily briefings on what is
happening
in the country that he has a duty to
protect
additionally the president
would have known just like the rest of
us know all of the reports
that were out there and publicly
available
how many of you receive calls saying to
be careful
on january 6 to be careful that day
i'm not i'm seeing reports it doesn't
seem
safe how much more the president of the
united states
donald trump is our commander-in-chief
absolutely had a duty
on a sworn oath to preserve protect and
defend
us and to do the same for the officers
under his command and he was not just
our commander-in-chief
he incited the attack the insurgents
were following his commands
as we saw when we read aloud his tweet
attacking the vice president and with
regard to the vice president
i'm sure they did have a good
relationship but we all know what can
happen to one
who has a good relationship with the
president when you decide to do
something that he doesn't like
i'm sure some of you have experienced
that when he turns against you
after you don't follow his command you
heard from my colleagues that when
planning this attack
the insurgents predicted that donald
trump would command the national guard
to help them
while he didn't do much better he may
not have commanded the guard to help
them
but it took way way too long for him to
command the guard
to help us this is all connected
we're talking about free speech this was
a pattern and practice of
months of activity that is the
incitement
that is the incitement the activity he
was engaged
in for months before january 6
not just the speech on january 6.
all of it in its totality is a
dereliction of duty
of the president of the united states
against the people
who elected him all of the people
of this country
the uh sergeant from alaska mr president
i send a question to
that to the desk for the former
president's council
senator alaska senator sullivan has a
question for
the house council and the clerk will
report the question
mr president for the former president's
council sorry about that thank you mr
president
the house manager said yesterday that
due process
is discretionary meaning the house is
not
required to provide and indeed did not
provide
in this snap impeachment any
constitutional protections
to a defendant in the house impeachment
proceedings
what are the implications for our
constitutional order of this new house
precedent combined with the senate's
power to disqualify from public office
a private citizen in an impeachment
trial
council has five minutes
that's a complicated question could i
have that read again please
the house managers said yesterday that
due process
is discretionary meaning the house is
not required to provide and indeed did
not provide in this snap impeachment
any constitutional protections to a
defendant
in house impeachment proceedings what
are the implications for our
constitutional order
of this new house precedent combined
with the senate's power to disqualify
from public office
a private citizen in an impeachment
trial
well first of all due process is never
discretionary
good lord the constitution
requires that an accused have the right
to due
process because the power
that a prosecutor has to take somebody's
liberty when they're prosecuting them
is the ultimate thing that we try to
save in this case
just now in the last two hours we've had
prosecutorial misconduct what they just
tried to do was say that it's
our burden to bring them evidence
to prove their case and it's not
it's not our burden to bring any
evidence forward at all
what's the danger well the danger is
pretty obvious
if a majority party
doesn't like somebody in the minority
party
and they're afraid they may lose the
election or if
it's somebody in the majority party and
there's a private citizen
who wants to run against somebody in the
majority party
well they could simply bring impeachment
proceedings and of course without due
process they're not going to be entitled
to a lawyer
they're not going to be entitled to have
notice of the charges against
them it puts us
into a position where we are the kind of
judicial system and governing body
that we're all very very afraid of
from what we left hundreds of years ago
and what regimes all around this world
that endanger us that's how they act
that's how they conduct themselves
without giving the accused
due process taking their liberty
without giving them just a basic
fundamental right under
the fifth through the 14th applied to
the states
due process if you
take away due process in this country
to from the accused
if you take that away there will be no
justice
and nobody nobody will be safe
but it's patently unfair for the house
managers
to bring an impeachment proceeding
without any again without any
investigation
at all and then stand up here and say
one
ah they had a chance to bring us
evidence
and two uh uh
let's uh let's uh let's see what we can
do
about uh flipping around somebody's
other constitutional rights to having
a lawyer or to having uh
to see the evidence at all it just gets
brought in without anybody as it was
here without anybody having an
opportunity
to review it beforehand they actually
sent it to us
on the 9th the day after we started this
so it's a really big problem the due
process clause
applies to this impeachment hearing
and it's been severely and extremely
violated this process is so
unconstitutional
because it violates due process i'm not
able to get into the jurisdiction part
the due process part should be enough to
give anybody
who loves our constitution and loves our
country
great pause to do anything
but acquit donald trump
thank you
mr president please uh senator from
connecticut
thank you mr president mr president i
send a question to the desk for the
house managers
the senator from connecticut senator
blumenthal has a question for the house
managers and the clerk will report the
question
former president trump and his attorneys
have cited the brandenburg the ohio case
in support of their argument
that the first amendment protects trump
did the brandenburg case prohibit
holding public officials accountable
through the impeachment process for the
incitement of violence
thank you mr president senators um
so let's start with the letter of uh
more than 140 constitutional law
professors
which i think they described as as
partisan
in nature that's a slur on the law
professors and i hope that they would
withdraw that there are very
conservative luminaries on that list
including the co-founder of the
federalist society
ronald reagan's former solicitor general
charles freed
as well as prominent law professors
across
the intellectual ideological and
jurisprudential spectrum
and they all called their first
amendment arguments frivolous which they
are
now they've been they've retreated to
the position of brandenburg versus ohio
they want their client to be treated
like a guy at the mob i think they said
a guy in the crowd who yells something
out even on that standard
this group of law professors said
there's a very strong argument
that he's he's guilty even under the
strict brandenburg standard why because
he incited imminent lawless action and
he intended to do it and it was likely
to cause it how do we know it was likely
to cause it
it did cause it they overran the capital
right so even if you want to hold the
president of the united states of
america to that minimal standard and
forget about his constitutional oath
of office but as i said before that
would be a dereliction of a legislative
duty on our part
if we said all we're going to do is
treat the president the united states
like
one of the people he summoned to
washington
to commit insurrection against us okay
the president swore
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
that's against all comers domestic or
foreign that's what ours says
right did he do that i know on the
contrary
he's like the fire chief he doesn't just
say
go ahead and shout fire in crowded
theater
he summons the mob and sends the mob to
go burn the theater down and when people
start
madly calling him and ringing alarm
bells he watches it on tv
and he takes his sweet time for several
hours he turns up the heat
on the deputy fire chief who he's mad at
because he's not making it
possible for him to pursue his political
objectives and then
when we say we don't want you to be fire
chief ever again
he starts crying about the first
amendment brandenburg was a case about a
bunch of a klansmen who
get assembled in a field and they
weren't near
anybody such that they could actually do
violent damage to people but they said
some pretty
repulsive racist things but the supreme
court said they weren't inciting
imminent lawless action
because you couldn't have a mob for
example break out
the way that this mob broke out and took
over the capital of the united states of
america
and by the way don't compare him to one
of those klansmen in the field
asserting their first amendments assume
that he were the chief of police of the
town who went down
to that rally and started calling for
uh you know a rally at the city hall and
then
nurturing that mob cultivating that mob
pulling them in over a period
of weeks and days naming the date and
the time in the place
riling them up beforehand and then just
saying be my guest
go and stop the steal come on back to
tom payne
use your common sense use your common
sense
that's the standard proof we want
they're already treating their client
like he's a criminal defendant they're
talking about beyond a reasonable doubt
that they think that we're making a
criminal case here
my friends the president the former
president is not going to spend one hour
or one minute in jail
this is about protecting our republic
and articulating and defining
the standards of presidential conduct
and if you want this
to be a standard for totally appropriate
presidential conduct
going forward be my guest but we're
headed for a very different kind of
country at that point
the senator from kansas i sent a
question to the desk
the senator from kansas mr marshall uh
has a question for
the council for the former president the
clerk will read the
question
the house manager's single article of
impeachment
is centered on the accusation that
president trump
singularly incited a crowd into a riot
didn't the house managers contradict
their own
charge by outlining the premeditated
nature and planning of this event
and by also showing the crowd was
gathered at the capitol
even before the speech started and
barriers were pushed over some 20
minutes
before the conclusion of president
trump's speech
yes the house managers contradicted
their own charge by outlining the
premeditated nature
and planning of this event and by also
showing the crowd gathered at the
capitol even before the speech started
and barriers were pushed over some 20
minutes before
the conclusion of president trump's
speech
the answer is yes and i want to take the
rest of my time to go back to the last
question because it was completely
missed by the house managers
brandenburg v ohio is an incitement case
it's not an elected official case
that's wood and bond and the whole
problem
that the house managers have in
understanding the first amendment
argument here
is that elected officials are different
than everybody else
he's talking about fire chiefs
fire chiefs are not elected officials
police officers aren't elected officials
elected officials
have a different uh a higher standard
from the holdings that i gave you the
highest protections
i should say it's not a higher standard
it's a higher protection
to your speech because of the importance
of political dialogue
because of what you all say in your
public debate about policy
about the things that affect all of our
lives
that's wicked important stuff and you
should be free to talk about that
in just about any way that you can
brandenburg comes into play from a
constitutional analysis perspective
when you're talking about incitement is
the speech
itself insightful to riot
or lawlessness one of the two
and the answer here is no in brandenburg
through
again bible believers
require you to look at the words of the
speech
you actually can't go outside the words
of the speech you're not allowed to in
the analysis
so all the time they're trying to spend
on tweets going back to 2015
or everything they want to focus on that
was said in the
hours and the days afterwards
are not applicable or relevant
to the scholastic inquiry
as to how the first amendment is applied
in this chamber in this proceeding
and so again you need to be focused on
what's the law
and then how do we apply it to this set
of facts
and so it's important to have that
understanding that elected officials
and fire chiefs are treated differently
under first amendment law
and that's the benefit of you all which
is the benefit
of us all because we do want you to be
able to speak freely
without fear that the majority party is
going to come in
and impeach you or come in and
prosecute you
to try to take away your seat where you
sit
now
that's not what the constitution says
should be done
but yes they do they do contradict
themselves of course
thank you
mr president the senator from maryland i
send a question to the desk for the
house managers
the center for maryland senator van
hollen has a
question for the managers the clerk will
report the
question
would you please respond to the answer
that was just given by the former
president's council
mr president thank you um i'm not quite
sure which question
um the senator was referring to but let
me quickly
uh just dispense of the council's
invocation again of bond versus
floyd this is a case i i know well and i
thank him for raising it julian bond
uh was a friend of mine he was a
colleague of mine at american university
he was a great civil rights hero and in
his case
he got elected to the georgia state
legislature
and is a member of st of snik the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee
the great committee headed up by the
great bob moses for a long time
he got elected to the georgia
legislature and they didn't
want to allow him to be sworn in they
wouldn't allow him to take his
oath of office because snick had taken a
position against the vietnam war
and so the supreme court said that was a
violation of his first amendment rights
not to allow him to be sworn in
that's the complete opposite of donald
trump not only was he sworn in
on january 20th 2017 he was president
for almost four years before
he incited this violent insurrection
against us and
he violated his oath of office that's
what this impeachment trial is about
his violation of his oath of office and
his refusal to uphold the law and take
care that the laws are faithfully
executed
please don't desecrate the name of
julian bond
a great american by linking him
with this terrible plot against america
that just took place in the storming of
the u.s capitol i'm going to turn over
to my colleague
ms plastic
thank you let's just be clear
president trump summoned the mob
assembled the mob
lit the flame everything that followed
was his doing
and although he could have immediately
and forcefully
intervened to stop the violence
he didn't in other words this attack
would not have happened without him
this attack is not about one's speech
most of you men would not have your
wives with one attempt at talking to her
it took numerous trials you had to build
it up
that's what the president did as well he
put
together the group that would do
what he wanted and that was to stop
the certification of the election so
that he could retain power
to be president of the united states in
contravention
of an american election
mr president the senator from florida i
send a question to the desk
the question from the senator from
florida
and it is to both sides the
clerk will read the question and the
house managers will go
first for the first two and a half
minutes
voting to convict the former president
would create a new precedent that a
former official
can be convicted and disqualified by the
senate
therefore is it not true that under this
new precedent
a future house facing partisan pressure
to
lock her up could impeach a former
secretary of state
and a future senate be forced to put her
on trial
and potentially disqualify from any
future
office
the house managers go first
mr president senators three quick points
here first of all
um i don't know how many times i can say
it the jurisdictional issue
is over it's gone the senate settled it
the senate entertained jurisdiction
exactly the way it has done since the
very beginning of the republic
in the blunt case in the belknap case
and you'll remember
both of them former officials and in
this case
we have a president who committed
his crimes against the republic while he
was in office
he was impeached by the house of
representatives while he was
in office so um you know
the the hypothetical suggested
by the gentleman from florida has no
bearing
on this case because i don't think
you're talking about an official who was
impeached while they were in office
for conduct that they committed while
they were in office
the council for the former president has
two and a half minutes thank you could i
have the question read again to make
sure i have it right
i can answer it directly
voting to convict the former president
would create a new precedent
that a former official can be convicted
and disqualified by the senate
therefore is it not true that under this
new precedent
a future house facing partisan pressure
to
lock her up could impeach a former
secretary of state
and a future senate be forced to put her
on trial
and potentially disqualify from any
future office
if you see it their way yes
if you do this the way they want it done
that could happen to
the example there a former secretary of
state
but it could happen to a lot of people
and that's not the way this is supposed
to work
and not only could it happen to a lot of
people it become much more regular
too but i want to address
that and i want you to be clear on this
mr raskin can't tell you
on what grounds you acquit
if you believe even though there was a
vote that there's jurisdiction
if you believe jurisdiction is
unconstitutional
you can still believe that if you
believe
that the house did not give appropriate
due process
in this that can be your reason to
acquit
if you don't think they met their burden
in proving incitement that these words
incited the violence
you can acquit mr raskin doesn't get to
give you under what grounds
you can acquit
and so you have to look at
what they've put on in its totality
and come to your own understanding as to
whether you think they've met their
burden
to impeach but the original question is
an
absolutely slippery slope that i don't
really think
anybody here wants to send this country
down
thank you
mr president the question to the desk
the senator from colorado sydney
question to the desk
and i i would note just for the uh
as the hour is tends to get late i would
note for
all uh council
as chief justice roberts noted on
january 21st 2020
signed the trial of charles swain in
1905
all parties in this chamber must refrain
from using language that is not
conducive to civil discourse
the senator from colorado senator
bennett
has a question for the house managers
and the clerk will read the
question
since the november election the georgia
secretary of state
the vice president and other public
officials
withstood enormous pressure to uphold
the lawful election of president biden
and the rule of law what would have
happened
if these officials had bowed to the
force
president trump exerted or the mob that
attacked
the capital
you
okay
the house managers have five minutes
i want to take a minute and remind
everybody about the incredible pressure
that donald trump was putting on
election officials in different states
in this country
and the intimidation that he was issuing
i want to remind everyone of the
background of donald trump's call
to one secretary of state the secretary
of state from georgia
mr raffensberger donald trump tried to
overturn the election
by any means necessary he tried again
and again
to pressure and threaten election
officials to overturn
the election results he pressured
michigan officials
calling them late at night and hosting
them at the white house
he did the same thing with officials in
pennsylvania
he called into a local meeting of the
pennsylvania legislature
and he also hosted them hosted them at
the white house where he pressured them
and in georgia it was even worse
he sent tweet after tweet attacking the
secretary of state
until mr raffesburger got death threats
to him
and his family his wife got a text that
said quote
your husband deserves facing a firing
squad
firing squad for doing his job
mr mr raffensburger stood up to him he
told the world that elections are the
bedrock of this society
and the votes were accurately counted
for donald trump's
opponent officials
like mr sterling warned trump that if
this continued
someone's going to get killed
but donald trump didn't stop he
escalated it even further
he made a personal call you heard that
call
because it was recorded the president of
the united states told a secretary of
state
that if he does not find votes he will
face criminal penalties
please senators consider that for a
second the president putting
all of this public and private pressure
on election officials
telling them that they could face
criminal penalties if they don't do
what he wants and not just
any number of votes that he was looking
for donald trump was asking the
secretary of state to somehow find
the exact number of votes donald trump
lost the state by
remember president biden won georgia by
11
779 votes in his own words
president trump said quote all i want to
do is this
i just want to find 11 780 votes
he wanted the secretary of state to
somehow find
the precise number plus one of votes
that he needed to win
as a congress and as a nation we cannot
be no
come to this conduct
if we are and if we don't set a
precedent against
it more presidents will do this in the
future
this will be a green light for them to
engage in that kind of pressure in that
kind of conduct
and this could have gone a very
different way if those election
officials had bowed
to the intimidation and the pressure of
the president of the united states
it would have meant that instead of the
american people deciding this election
president trump alone would have decided
this american election that's exactly
what was at stake
and that's exactly what he was trying to
do
he intended wanted to and tried
to overturn the election by any means
necessary
he tried everything else that he could
to do to win
he started inciting the crowd issuing
tweet after tweet
issuing commands to stop the count stop
the steal
worked up the crowd sent to save the
date
so it wasn't just one speech or one
thing he was trying everything
he was pressuring elected officials he
was riling up his base telling him the
election had been stolen from them
that it had been stolen from him
it was a combination of things that only
donald trump
could have done and for us to believe
otherwise is to think that somehow
a rabbit came out of a hat and this mob
just showed up here on their own
all by themselves this is dangerous
senators
in the future of our democracy truly
rest in your hands
mr president the senator from texas mr
president i
send a question to the desk
the senator from texas mr cornyn has a
question
for both uh council for the former
president
and the house manager the clerk will
read the question and the uh
who recognized first the council for the
former president
the house managers have argued that if
the senate cannot convict
former officers then the constitution
creates a january exception
pursuant to which a president is free to
act with impunity
because he is not subject to impeachment
conviction
and removal and or disqualification
but isn't a president subject to
criminal prosecution
after he leaves office for acts
committed in office
even if those acts are committed in
january
the senator from texas question raises a
very
very important point there is no such
thing as a january
exception to impeachment there is only
the text of the constitution which makes
very clear that a former president is
subject to criminal sanction
after his presidency for any illegal
acts he commits
there is no january exception to
impeachment
there is simply a way we treat high
crimes
and misdemeanors allegedly committed by
a president when he
is in office impeachment
and how we treat criminal behavior by a
private citizen
when they are not in office
the house managers
um thank you for this excellent question
wouldn't a president who decides to
commit his crimes
in the last few weeks in office like
president trump by
inciting an insurrection against the
county of electoral college votes be
subject
to criminal prosecution by the u.s
attorney for the district of columbia
for example the department of justice
well of course he would be um but that's
true of the president
regardless of when he commits his
offenses in office in other words that's
an argument for
prosecuting him if he tried to stage an
insurrection
against the union in his third year in
office or his second year in office
you could say well he could be
prosecuted afterwards the reason that
the framers
gave congress the house the power to
impeach
the senate the power to try convict
remove and disqualify was to protect
the republic it's not a vindictive power
i know a lot of people were very angry
with donald trump about these terrible
events that took place
we don't come here in anger contrary to
what you've heard today
we come here in the spirit of protecting
our republic and that's what it's all
about
but their january exception would
essentially invite
presidents and other civil officers to
run
rampant in the last few weeks in office
on the theory
that the house and the senate wouldn't
be able to get it together in time
certainly according to their demands for
months and months of investigation
wouldn't be able to get it together in
time in order to vindicate the
constitution
that can't be right that can't be right
we know that the peaceful transfer of
power
is always the most dangerous moment for
democracies around the world
talk to the diplomats talk to the
historians they will tell you
that is a moment of danger that's when
you get the coups
that's when you get the insurrections
that's when you get the seditious plots
and you know what you don't even have to
read history for that you don't even
have to consult
the framers you don't have to look
around the world it just
happened to us the moment
when we were just going to collect the
already certified electoral college
votes
from the states by the popular
majorities within each state
except for maine and nebraska which do
it by congressional district as well as
statewide but otherwise it's just the
popular majorities in the states and
we're about to certify it
and we got hit by a violent
insurrectionary mob
don't take our word for it listen to the
tapes unless they're going to claim
those are fabricated too
and the people are yelling this is our
house now
and where are the blank votes and show
us the votes
etc thank you
the majority leader
mr president it's my understanding there
are no further questions on either side
the republican leader that's correct i
know no further questions on our side
i ask unanimous consent that the time
for questions and answers be considered
expired
without objection so ordered now mr
president
uh i ask unanimous consent that it be in
order for myself and senator mcconnell
to speak for up to one minute each and
then it be in order for me to make a
unanimous consent to request as if in
legislative session
the objections ordered the senator from
new york thank you mr president
and mr president in a moment i will ask
the senate to pass legislation
that would award capitol police officer
eugene goodman
the congressional gold medal
in the weeks after the attack on january
the 6th
the world learned about the incredible
incredible bravery
of officer goodman on that fateful day
here in this trial we saw a new video
powerful video
showing calmness under pressure his
courage in the line of duty
his foresight in the midst of chaos and
his willingness to make himself
a target of the mob's rage so that
others might reach
safety officer goodman is in the chamber
tonight
officer goodman thank you
[Laughter]
so
[Laughter]
republican leader mcconnell oh i'm sorry
okay cool i just want to say i think we
can all agree
that eugene goodman deserves the highest
honor congress can bestow
but i just before we move to pass this
legislation i want to be clear
that he was not alone that day the
nation saw
and has now seen numerous examples of
the heroic conduct of the capitol police
the metropolitan police the swat teams
that were with us on january 6th here in
the capitol protecting us
our heartfelt gratitude extends to each
and every one of them
particularly now as members of the force
continue to bear scars seen
and unforeseen from the events
of that disgraceful day let us give them
all the honor and recognition they so
justly
[Applause]
deserve
mr president the republican leader
pleased to join
the majority leader's request january
6 was a day of fear for those who work
here in the capitol and of sadness for
many more watching
from afar but that awful day also
introduced our nation to a group of
heroes
whom we in congress were already proud
to call our colleagues
and to whom we owe a great death
in the face of lawlessness the officers
of the u.s capitol lived out
the fullest sense of their oaths
if not for the quick thinking and
bravery of officer eugene
goodman in particular people in this
chamber may not have escaped
that day unharmed officer goodman's
actions reflect a deep personal
commitment
to duty and brought even greater
distinction upon all his brave
brothers and sisters in uniform
so i'm proud the senate is taking this
step forward recognizing his heroism
with the highest honor we can bestow
[Applause]
so mr president as if in legislative
session
i ask unanimous consent that the
committee on banking housing and urban
affairs be discharged from further
consideration
of s35 and then at the senate proceed to
its immediate consideration
the objection and the parkour report
s35 a bill to award a congressional gold
medal
to officer eugene goodman
without objection the committee is
discharged
and the senate now proceeds to the
measure mr president i ask unanimous
consent that the van
hollen substitute amendment which is at
the desk be considered and agreed to
the bill as amended be considered read a
third time and passed
and the motions to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon
with the table sword now mr president i
ask unanimous consent
the trial adjourn until 10 a.m tomorrow
saturday february 13th
and that this also constitute the
adjournment of the senate
without objection and we are adjourned
till 10 o'clock tomorrow
you